oh you're ruining my channel
[Music]
hi i'm nikki glazer and i am back to
answer the internet would you rather
orgasm every time you heard all-star by
smash mouth or all-star or hear all-star
every time you orgasm i don't hear
all-star that much i would actually love
to come a little bit more in my life
every time i hear all-star when do you
hear hey now maybe at the baseball game
that's what's funny is like you may be
in the grocery store
like they're probably like
you're walking you know you get in the
car with your parents they're putting on
like an oldie
i'll just look like i'm having like a
little bit of uh
you know an episode like i can really
mask an orgasm but wouldn't it be so
much better i'm not gonna be like oh
okay sing hey now this is what it will
look like
oh these grapes over here
starting now
[Applause]
so you get the combat you want to come
and then the music drops that's how i
calm when i went on a call i like going
like that
like i
yeah
i just gave away too much if every time
you finished sex a song played what song
would you want it to be probably
delicate by taylor swift because i just
like that song and that's what i wake up
to this ain't for the best
my reputations i don't know it's just
like soothing and it's i will never get
tired of it because i hear it every day
anyway you know we get tired of the guy
you're [ __ ] uh
there the guy is already
um there's pictures of her around so i
can come okay so if
they're like covered in my room okay if
you were on an old episode of room
raiders what would you be most afraid
what would you be most afraid of being
found probably the drawer of sex toys
that i have because it's just
it's messy it also has like spray tan
cans in it and it's like and i was just
talking about this but like
when you don't
just but you don't clean
your toys like right after which
sometimes you don't want to because
you're just like
tired and ashamed of what you've looked
at and you need to clear your cookies um
the stuff it dries and then the next
time you go to grab it um
it like like in the toy moves it like
flakes off like like snow like i always
think of christmas time it gets me in
the christmas spirit when i like go
through a drawer to look for something
and it's like ding ding and i always
hear jingle bells being played in my
head when i do that so i think it would
be yeah uh that a come crusted toy would
be the thing i wouldn't want them to
find a roommate um if you could pick one
country to run what would it be ew no
gross you'll get like assassinated and
it's just like a lot of meetings would
you be celibate for a year to be able to
have sex with any girl you wanted after
the year was up yes a hundred percent
yes yes yes yes and i think you know who
it would be
for the best no you wouldn't have sex
taylor swift would you i'm not going to
say yes because i don't want to like
that's like rude to her if she doesn't
want it but
but it's also rude if you say no yes
you think so
more than anyone you think that she's
like kinky and like good in bed you just
want to do it
if she wanted to obviously i feel bad
even answering the question i'm ugh
you're ruining my channel
if you had to choose one movie series
and one tv series to watch the rest of
your life what would you choose movie
series
uh i don't know like what meg ryan and
tom hanks like falling in love over and
over like anything or everyone and then
tv series uh 30 rocker v beep probably
because veep is just
so many jokes would you rather be the
most attractive person in the world yes
but blind the best singer in the world
but deaf or the best chef in the world
but why would anyone want to be the best
chef in the world who cares about that
do we love chefs that much there's some
celebrity chefs i know but also wolfgang
puck yeah and have no taste it was
covered or be giselle
and you'd be oh wait you'd be blind i
didn't think about the blind i just saw
it sucks being blind so silent ruins
your life okay hold on let me really
think about this okay i would want to be
oh blind sucks so much probably
wait but the best singer would i sing
deaf though but people just didn't know
for some sound a little bit
don't you
talk with people i would say you know i
would but i just can't my voice hurts
right now and it's not like they would
hear it okay so i um um
i would not want to be any of the i
guess best singer in death because death
is like probably the disability i can at
least [ __ ] up your life is just be the
[ __ ] chef no taste you could be
healthy and eat good food you're right i
would want to be the chef what a
turnaround
um would you rather your dog would you
rather your i think we're learning i
can't read would you rather your pet
have a dog's personality and a cat body
or a cat's personality and a dog body i
like dogs and i love the fact that cats
like no but cats don't like you and
they're kind of a little that's why you
want the personality right okay it looks
like cats
i don't like dogs because of the shape
of them or like they're like their noses
are so cute
yeah yeah i brought a cat with a dog
personality what are the best starburst
flavors pink
duh keep going you order them pink
uh pink yellow um
that green flavor that's in the the
green yeah
okay the originals orange pink yellow
red like whatever yeah pink yellow
orange red red
yeah or in trend if you had to move it
to a different place on the body where
would you put the vagina
um
probably like a little bit like more up
like just shift it uh like a couple
centimeters up it just it's easier
access like from the front so you could
have more like yeah i mean it would have
to be and i don't even like doggy so i
don't even need like it yeah it would be
a little bit more flat my [ __ ] would
just be like easier i don't know then so
like the dick would have to be like down
and like straight
yeah you know kind of upset i didn't
know that i did not know i thought all
men's boners were 93 i cannot that was
the wildest thing but i learned i was
like you can go all the way up that is
why
yeah i just don't want it anywhere else
like that maybe like the back of my neck
like where you would put a tattoo so you
couldn't see it if you're trying to be
classy
and then if you are like really feeling
like what about you like on your hand
and just like
you know it's like pow pow pow powder
that's so dirty yeah i would be getting
utis
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications make sure you click thumbs
up for the like hit that bell icon